[Music]
this week the government lost three
votes in the House of Commons within the
space of two hours and won the dubious
honor of becoming the first government
in history to be found in contempt of
parliament labor are of course I should
expect piling on the pressure with the
shallow breaths that secretary telling
me on this show last week that a
confidence motion in the government
would be inevitable if the brexit vote
is lost well joining us now is one of
jeremy corbyn's most trusted allies and
a key member of his inner circle the
shadow cabinet minister john Trickett
thank you very much for being with us
well in these very unpredictable times
we're trying to give our viewers a bit
of a sense about what might unfold next
week so if the reason they does lose
this vote as we expect her to will
Labour be calling a confidence mission
let's see what happens I mean like the
present focus is on making sure we
defeat this really bad deal which would
be presented to the House of Commons we
don't know that the the media is saying
we should we aren't going to win the
vote whether we know or not will then
see what our tactics need to be
following that and there's a number of
possible scenarios and nothing is
possible to guess in advance exactly
what's going to happen last week on the
show that the chatter brexit secretary
ko stahma told me it was inevitable that
labor would call her confidence motion
if she lost the votes so what's changed
nothing has changed we simply don't know
what is going to happen on Tuesday night
and remember it's quite possible or
coined again to the media and who knows
that the whole vault may be put off and
that mrs. may goes back to you're not
the big question the big which is faced
in the country is how in a democratic
society do we retain consent of the
people
I think the brexit vote shows that a
significant body of people do not
consent to the direction in which the
country is being going and I represent
if a right breaks it central when am I
see is one of the strongest breaks it
areas those people believe that their
voice would be listened to and that we
would have a proper breaks it
which would put jobs first that is not
what we've got we've got a deal which is
barged and Mrs May said there's no other
alternative let's see what happens on
Tuesday night we need to defeat this and
we also by the way need to make sure
that there's no cliff edge fall out
falling out of brains inadvertently with
the disaster which would then follow
you're talking now I got some pretty big
themes but people feeling listen to
disconnected so what I don't understand
then is calling a confidence motion
would be Labour's big chance of getting
into power why would you possibly give
that up we're not ruling anything out at
the present time I think we need to see
what happens on the night nobody really
knows and I've sat with government
ministers you're speaking to some of
this morning but nobody knows that we
could have the clearer idea if you're
going on a journey you need to take one
step at a time
and the truth is we are facing a big
moment in our country's history let's be
honest about it the first thing is to
persuade the country this is the wrong
deal to persuade the House of Commons
when that has happened though we a
series of votes probably one of which is
to say that there should be we should
rule out that the Haskell's rules out a
deal which simply leaves us falling off
the edge that is quite an important
debate as well what subsequently happens
and exactly how its choreographed we
need to see now clearly we have a view
as to what ought to happen but we are
not the government we are not the
largest party and missus may still holds
most of the cars in relation to what
happens after the vote though I think
time is really running out for her and
if you can tell me whether she'll be
still be the Prime Minister on Tuesday
evening then perhaps I can tell you what
we do what exactly we will do next so
there's a number of scenarios Microsoft
well sadly I'm not a member of the
Shadow Cabinet you've got a lot more
influence than me well it may be that
she isn't quite know either by the way I
think things have run out control and
look the whole way in which is
negotiated this has been an absolute
disaster from the start why would you
begin at the right at the start to say
that all these millions of people who
are European citizens
here for many many years paid there Taos
contributed to our economy should now
become a point of negotiation I mean
that would cause friends from they want
be fat she said right from the beginning
hasn't even on ones to guarantee the
rights that people were I don't believe
she has from the very beginning and it
caused great offense if you're the prime
minister or a president of another
country and you've got maybe tens of
thousands of citizens working in Britain
you want to know from day one that those
jobs and those people are going to be
secure I hear so and I think that
language has been used by some Tories
about putting the white flag and
capitulation it implies that the Europe
is somehow our enemies rather than our
allies Friends of long-term neighbors so
you described the negotiation as a
disaster there and how to say it has
been quite an extraordinary week for the
government we've got over a hundred
conservative M he's saying that they
can't support the Prime Minister's deal
they become the first government in
history to be found in contempt of
parliament so my question to you is why
hasn't labor had a big lead in the polls
we could have a look at the latest poll
for example I know this is just one poll
but and Ipsos MORI poll on friday
effectively saying that you're
deadlocked if the government is in such
disarray then why aren't you so far
ahead well look I think we've all looked
that the polls are only reveals so much
the polls food very very badly wrong in
the past in the election we were at 26
points I think when the election was
called only last year that was another
disastrous decision by the government by
the way we finished that over 40 points
on your show another 20 points look I
think the country is genuinely watching
what's happening I think it's just like
sent confused and worried anxious about
the future okay yeah and look at the
kind of news which is happening all
around us you know the universal credit
the explosion of wealth for the richest
and other people living in very
difficult conditions the United Nations
saying there are 15 million of our
fellow citizens living in poverty
250,000 children in Yorkshire in poverty
I mean a government you know to do
several things at once multitask but
this can't this can't can't even single
task now and I'm keen to you
talk to you about Labor's positions that
you're talking about people are feeling
uncertain or concerned so let's try and
find out what Labor's position is if
there is a lecture and you have to tell
us them and does labour support a seven
second referendum is that something you
would like to see what we've said and I
think you know this the conference our
labor hajeck conference decided that a
second referendum should be one of the
options which are available tours but
again if if anybody can tell me is that
be how this is going to emerge over time
and I think we can give you a clear
motive you should have a chance to state
what happens I haven't of course we can
we are just about following events it's
really serious stuff of course you're
trying to pull me into a what-if
question Mike what Labour's policy is no
they say what if if the vote happens on
Tuesday night and we lose the vote if
they'd sorry if the Tories lose the vote
what would then happen subsequently and
I don't think we can say that referendum
is the only possible alternative and let
me explain why because as you know we
said that an election is probably the
preferred choice and the reason why we
said that is because if a render if a
referendum were to take place in the
present Parliament who's to say that we
will get out the gridlock which the
Parliament is in and the election allows
us to refresh the Monday have a
conversation with the wider population
and come back to Parliament poll with
some new MPs and different point of view
and take the argument forward of that
stage so our preferred option very very
strongly is that we refresh the
parliament though we are ready to be
former minority government should that
be necessary and it could happen on
Wednesday morning and to begin to reset
the negotiation and take the country
forward in a much better direction I
just want to talk a little bit more
about this second referendum question
because actually said you support the
seat that voted fighting for brexit in
West Yorkshire and what do you think the
reaction would be my constituents in in
places like where you represent if there
was another vote
well I think if people feel that a
privileged political elite as decided by
subterfuge to find a way of reversing
the previous referendum that would cause
us some difficulty and rightly so
because I started this discussion with
you describing this sense in the country
of what on earth is happening this
withdrawal of consent so I think we need
to show to the country that we've been
through the various different options
and at some point if the referendum
becomes absolutely necessary it's at
that point that it takes place I bear in
mind this it can take months six or
seven months to organize a referendum
because there's no law which allows us
to do it so we have to pass a law we
have to decide what the question is we
have to renew the people the people on
the voting lists and then there has to
be a period of time for the referendum
so we think the earliest it can take
place is Pauline May or June
we'd have gone past the March deadline
which mrs. Mayer's imposed on the
country so there are some issues about a
referendum which need to be addressed as
well but look in the meantime every day
which passes is another day near it's a
potential disaster and we say we need to
reset the negotiations straight away on
a new basis and come forward with a
different way of running our country in
its relationship with your aura do you
think that some MPs from all parties
from labor from the Conservatives and in
southern seats particularly London do
you think maybe we understand the sense
of betrayal that some voters would feel
if there was another referendum I can't
speak for other MPs but what I know is D
is visceral it's Deeping people soul
that this country needs to change
direction in the constituency I
represent and I think across the North
generally and rightly so because look
what's happening to the communities
which were the source of Britain's
wealth in the Industrial Revolution over
the centuries after that and now that
these areas have been be industrialized
the jobs which are coming a temporary
often part-time poorly paid insecure our
young people don't have a future unless
they move out of the area
and I think all of that weighs heavily
on people's minds whether they're
thinking of the future I think Bragg's
it was a vote to say we do not like the
direction of the country and so Labour's
response has been a big response we do
need to change directions substantially
and fundamentally and heading a new
direction to rebuild all those
communities with all that in mind doing
do you want to see us leave that you you
know our line has been that no I'm
asking what do you think what's your my
view is clear my history everybody knows
as I was against the varnish the coal
market all those years ago as a young
man over the years though the economy
has become very tied up with Europe and
therefore I think it's not easy for us
visit to disentangle so my position and
our position by the way has been that we
need to stay but we need to do
fundamental and radical reform because
status quo things as they are now let's
you want to stay now even after having
the referendum no we've decided that we
are leaving because we've listened to
the people's vote which was an
instruction from the people a kind of
trance rabbit wean us and the people to
accept the decision so you think you
were asking what our position was at the
time of them I mean our position is
quite clear we accept the results of the
referendum and we think that there is a
way through this and by the way we think
there's a way of not dividing the
country at the moment we have a
government which is trying to divide the
country on the lines of how they voted
in the referendum I think there's a way
of being the country about together
again this this government has been
appalling that in the way it's divided
people one against the other and that
must stop okay John Trickett thank you
very much thank you
[Music]
you